way before slave in Africa you will know
about it no the slavery happened by the
Spanish for them this is even the
Muslims in Andalusia and the first
people that were taken as slaves from
Spain to to South America they were the
Muslims and the Russia and majority of
them they were Arabs
Israelite because I'm an Arab and in the
Bible says it's gonna understand this
this school that is ambiguous statements
because what happened now okay the
Israelites they say to you Greek we are
on the bottom but we're gonna be on the
top so we're gonna stay with people so
those who couldn't be enslaved by them
they're gonna say oh I'm gone so we are
by the The Chosen because you get the
slave so I'm saying you cannot uh
through conclusion based upon ambiguous
statements but no doubt there's
something we have to to to to to to
mention here no
are white
that's not the reality
it's like all right black mix because
you have a narration that Prophet
Muhammad told us that Jesus was a light
skin
and Moses was dark skinned that's in our
source Islamic sources Musa he was a
dark skin in the stand by the way they
picture them here white man with the
blue eyes and a blonde hair you
understand so what I'm saying what
happened now this black movement they're
going to extreme because of the
extremism of the white racism
so we don't we don't we don't cure
disease with another disease we have to
be just understand for example correct
King James yeah
okay let me show you something keep
dreams
that's King James
I'm gonna show you something in
you know about Isaiah 42
yeah
42.
Isaiah 42.
I'll show you anyway
Isaiah 42
yes the servant comes to glorify the
Lord so that is a prophecy by the way
yeah but let's read it
yeah Gemma you can get the like they
actually behold my servants yeah
[Music]
my servant uphold
my elect one yeah
uh you know my soul the lights
I put my spirit upon him he will bring
four of Justice to the John's house who
are the Giants house
the chance has non-juice the nunchus
yeah you know Israelites they're called
the giant times yeah so this man is
coming for the Johnsons yeah
okay
I don't know about the mic now it
started yeah
foreign
in Genesis let me show you something in
Genesis here we go
25-13 and these were the names of the
sons of Ishmael
yeah but by their name according to
their generation the third book of
Israel
so Isaiah 42
let the village that killed that in
heaven
if you Google yeah
me
mountains
to the mountain of Cellar is inside you
know
Mountain Saudi Arabia
so so so this prophecy is because Torah
is the Torah can be the five books also
the old testamentura so my point here is
this prophecy doesn't fit for what
Muhammad prophet Muhammad he was
because
Israelites
remember my favor on you because I
believe Allah even is the light over
other nations yeah
upon you and fulfill my promise I will
fulfill yours what is Allah promise that
if this promise come to you you have to
follow him
that's why there's no salvation now
he said by following the last prophet
Muhammad
so the question you ask yourself what is
man doing here who's this person you
know even the Jewish rabbi is different
some of them said it's about Jacob Jacob
was before him
about Jesus
okay Jesus never came from the Giant's
house
every prophet in the Israelite came
through for the Israelites he's coming
for the Giant's house
and the only everybody I came originally
for the Giants of the Moon trees is the
prophet what happened
a lot of information
oh so what we're saying to you look here
god is perfect
that's good regrets
that's good to regrets
bro take care of my phone I'm going to
the shop come back so what you do I come
back you're gone into my phone so I said
I regret
because I didn't know that you're gonna
take it you understand now when you come
to the Bible look at this
Samuel 15 yeah
okay watch this eleven
no from 10 now the word of the Lord came
to Samuel saying I greatly regret that I
have set up Soul as a king
foreign
back from following me
how God regrets doesn't make any I don't
just regret greatly yeah
regret big regret yeah you know that's
why we believe in Moses we believe in
Abraham we believe in Jesus
right but we don't believe we believe in
the Torah as well but we believe it's
been corrupted we believed Israelites
due to slaver happened to them by the
Persians and the Babylon they were
influenced even by the the Pharaoh they
were influenced for example we can see
the influence the influence of the
aggressive teaching in the Old Testament
let me ask you
how the languages came about how yeah
speak in different languages
but aesthetically speaking to Allah
Allah told us is a sign Allah creates us
with a different signs of different
languages but according to the Bible no
for the Bible
because I speak in different languages
because
11.
look here we go please
now the whole earth had one language and
one speech so the whole after speaking
one language yeah
and he came to pass as they journeyed
from the East that they found a plane in
the land of China and they dwelt there
then they said to one another came come
let us make bricks and bake them truly
and they had uh was that remote or
something but yeah the point I'm gonna
I'm gonna try to mention the main points
here and they said come let us build
ourselves the city and Tower
whose stop is in the heavens let us make
a name for ourselves this will be
discussed abroad over the face of the
whole Earth but the Lord came down to
see the city and so I wish the sons of
man has built so it's just about
yourself explain to you so they start
speaking one language
so God came down and he said everyone
speaking one language and they start
beating Two Towers go became worried and
investors became World here but God he
said the angel to close them speaking
different languages because God said now
you're speaking one language
and they're within two towers nothing
can stop them but we know there's a
Babylon teaching the Babylon Pagan is a
teaching that they used to believe he'll
be two towers you can reach God over
through God
but we know regardless how Tower is tall
you never reach God
in the stand bro so you can see paganism
s
like this he doesn't want to show you
the problems
reasoning
with another destination these tools we
use them to recognize the truth they
understand
so you know when you come to Islam
worship one God it's perfect but yeah
it's better good they create everything
it's not by your skin color it's more
about your lineage it's about what you
believe in your action
it's that because how God creates a
white man as a white person by his evil
and a white an Arab and a non-arab
except for what except with the fight
and righteousness
God alone and he followed his kitchen
the way he wants you then he would be
better than one million
it's done but if you follow the Satan
regardless who you are if there's a
light or not that will not benefit you
before you create
is based upon Justice
you know
like you know there's many prophecies
that Prophet Muhammad
and we can see it right now
foreign buildings
but Muhammad told that the Muslim the
future of the Arabs more specifically
they will start competing in building
two buildings remember Prophet Muhammad
existed 1400 years ago
in the middle of desert let me ask you
where is the tallest tower or building
in the world
goodbye
goodbye bro Dubai 50 years ago was a
pure desert let alone 1 years ago and
now outside it's completion of them
one thousand four hundred years ago
prophesizing about something observed
right now
also you said it would come a time when
a woman be dressed but naked at the same
time to redress by Nick at the same time
I mean you can see everyone now
clothes that women are wearing it's
crazy
again
this area the carnival day it was crazy
bro how it was the Masjid and it was
just mental in
they say no this woman's rights
yeah oh and freedom in the start
our right is about to take us to follow
that's the woman's right that's meant
right that's not what he wants to see
from the woman
that of course the man is gonna tell her
I want to see your body so he's gonna
come from what women's rights
or women's Freedom you gotta play with
the terminology yeah the true meaning of
freedom for you and I to be the servant
of the Creator that's the true meaning
of freedom as for following our desires
and our societies that is the true
meaning of slavery
you're a slave of your desires that's
that's the worst type of Slavery to be
safe of your desires say it Milo and the
true meaning of freedom to be the state
of your creator the one who created
everything the Almighty
the stambro so there's many promises
I'll give you another prophecy Prophet
Muhammad or in the Quran Allah
Satan will inspire people to change
Allah's creation
six and would inspire people to check
Allah's creation require enough man is
completely manifest because everything
is through that woman or to be a woman
woman she's fine she wants to see
because they feel something so I mean
the example I always believed imagine
said to you bro listen I feel I should
have bought as a harmless person even
though I kill himself no problem with it
but I feel I should have gone as an
armless person and I still feel like an
armless person would you help me to cut
off my arm look at how
our feelings
because I feel I have the urge to Rob
someone I'm going to say because I feel
like it that I'm gonna implement it I
have to fight it because Satan our minds
our feelings it's done
Allah mentioned that 1400 years ago
what's up Linda
it's lgbtq business
ES
man
yeah bro but we have to stand for what
we believe
Islam it's the most Angus
you know Islam I guess I guess
that's why the prophets and Messengers
they will not follow us their society
they'll follow the truth look at this
Prophet Muhammad his Society
there was the items they never said ah
they worshiping the idols I'm just I
have to follow them no these two go to
the top of the mountain and reflect upon
Allah's creation
and no way the Creator all of this is
Idol or an angel no then Allah Gabriel
what do you think so far make sense
yeah bro Islam is simple you know
because you go alone
follow his teaching you know
everybody
I'm gonna try to do it Allah
[Laughter]
this book is written in a language
we don't have the original language for
this movie
we don't have him
Arabic language
the pure language the ocean language the
Allah sent down the Revelation so we
don't know really what Jesus said for
Moses said you understand but also what
was going to say one of the Miracles
Allah made it easy to be memorized Allah
said yes
and easy to be memorized
now if you go to Africa go to Caribbean
Europe America
in Muslims at the age of nine percent
and word for word letter for letter
literally you know sometimes the people
that memorize the Quran they don't even
speak the Arabic language because
you know the whole book in Arabic
language quite hard the example I always
give imagine all of us here we don't
know imagine we don't know uh French yes
we don't know friendship and all of us
we memorize this book in French but none
of us know fresh here
this book as you know if the Muslims and
the Jewish Israelite the Christians all
of them decide to burn the scripture the
only scripture that will remain with us
is the Quran because it has been
memorized
you know the Muslim children can bring
it back into the written form even
though the Muslim schools
that shows the power of this book
it's the guidance everything you know
that's why there's a huge system
because the only religion that I stand
in firm and get the evil agenda is that
true
look what he said he said you know he's
a multi-millionaire
I knew the only religion that is not
backing now and it's turned in front and
one of the things that distinguished
this level from any religion is the
wonders of Allah
Allah
we have direct contact with Allah direct
relationship Allah that's the beauty
foreign
we're here every Friday if you've got
any questions yeah you're more than
welcome to come through another chat
brother you know nice because
what I was gonna say you know I'll tell
you something yeah one day we have to
live this life we're going to die no
doubt
you know people that love you so much
they will never spent even a nice review
is a degree
you'll be by yourself
so we should not just follow our fathers
you know
he did not follow his own father he's so
fast
wherever the truth is for the truth
that's what a lot of views you know for
some people they say to you oh your
forefathers were taken worshiping so
what does that mean
because they want to go about our
forefather let's go watch the first man
Adam what was Adam Adam of the Muslim
meaning he submits himself to God Alone
this is that means submission to submit
stuff to God
but again it's not about following our
forefathers if they will follow the
truth yes but I'm gonna follow them
because they are my forefathers
that's what I'm saying
bro where are you coming down yeah
English
than Jamaican yes
yeah
it makes sense
told me that even though I was speaking
to the brother here that one day we're
going to die bro
You're Gonna Leave This Life
it is accept them
how many people left the house they
never come back
no four games
that you know what is talking to the
cameras in today
because no one is safe from them yeah
imagine if you die today may Allah
forbid what would be your excuse before
your almighty God
and your previous sins are wiped away
they're raised bye-bye
yeah
I was selling more solution
istanbro you know because
I should worship my Creator be grateful
to him you know while we speak it love
benefits from God's blessings that the
oxygen in out you know
die and you go to hospital
you gain it for free bro that's the
first one which is accepting you create
a lot then Muhammad is the last message
we believe in Moses however Jesus
teaching was corrupted by Ford and
Constantine
instead imagine you know why it's crazy
bro you know food and Constantine
food
Paul and Constantine both of them they
had quarter caught a vision yeah yeah
and they changed the teacher of Jesus
it's only become Muslim you are
following the true teaching of Jesus
which is the true meaning of the Oneness
of God worship Allah directly we don't
have to wash Allah we pray to Allah you
don't go even through prophet Muhammad
yes we follow his teaching how to preach
Allah directly
make sense
step by step
is about the cake
I told you about the cake yeah same
thing step by step because understand
we're coming from sometimes you think
you know what if I become Muslim now
I've stopped everything no bro but the
most important thing is the Oneness
Allah the first kid of Islam because
then the prayer because you know what
whoever Allah told us to do is good for
us
good for you
stay away from something because he
cares about you and he wants good for
you as well
stand to share that and it's clear and
believe it makes sense to you until it
becomes enough
because you have nothing don't let the
shaytan prevent you right I can say in
Arabic then repeat after me in English
step by step
and just commentary on that yeah in
terms of like you know some additional
note
we never had a person ever come back
after taking a shahada becoming a Muslim
ever say you know
I wish I never done that they always
come back and said why didn't I do that
quicker why because the feeling not just
any old feeling it's the truth that
you've accepted and your heart
You See Your Heart Take Care how does it
feel
how does your heart feel with what
you're saying
no it made sense yeah
somewhere
that's what I know yeah
something I would have to I'll say I'll
talk to my friend about I know that in
depth but you don't you know what to say
to you
know everything yeah
you understand because me and myself I
don't know everything me myself are
still struggling with something to
understand but if the foundation is
clear and it makes sense yes
because you don't lose anything rather
you win a profit you win Prophet
Muhammad if you live yeah
if you live with the chef becoming a
Muslim and you die
foreign
you know Islamic gives you your right
and the woman's rights
it's tempted you to have a what they
call it to become to give you true
meaning of freedom
you've got the true meaning of statement
when you when you become a slave of your
desires you understand that's society
and the true meaning of freedom when you
worship your creator wish Allah alone
the reason is
no pressure on you I've encouraging you
because I got the reward you're not
gonna give me no money but I got the
reward from Allah which is greater
reward God willing and establish alive
is that you become more
my brother than my own blood brother
because the Brotherhood of Islam is
stronger than the blood brother
you understand because we are brothers
in the foreign
reasons
because you don't have to learn all of
that now if you want to learn how to
drive
you're not going to learn how to jump is
outside the car you have to go inside
the car start learning
then that's why we become Muslim then
you learn while you sleep more and more
istanbro
don't let a pig stop you bro
we had it many times we are people like
you when it's out what's your name
Casey where people like you many times
okay we've been doing it for the last 15
years and people say you know like a
brother says
Muslim they never came back and said you
know what I wish I never done it they
always say I wish I did it earlier
of Allah
you know Satan
state is our clear enemy you ready
you know it's good because we bear
witness to you embracing the faith you
know you know we Embrace how we hug each
other you know these sort of things
these memories there not just for the
sake of memories but it's something that
you know your look back and think raw
look shaytan was probably playing with
me the devil was proper playing with me
but once you accept it's like
all of that I feel better now
yeah I mean because you don't have to do
with someone else yeah
and the Believers we embrace you you
know we become brothers in faith
but it's up to you as we always say man
but if your heart's inclined to what
we're saying if your heart right now
agrees with the logic he's mobilizing in
this discussion
come on man yeah
like how many people are walking past
many people but Allah chose you and him
even him I don't know how he explores
but you will see more closer even if it
makes sense to him and everything so I'm
saying bro become Muslim stop praying
step by step you know hey how you say
it's here it's definitely one else and
of course in the morning Witnesses
she's Christian yeah
so yeah speak to your mom first yeah
okay
but what we'll say to you are you
promised to live tomorrow are you
promised
experience
people saying and they never regret it
to understand because okay tell your mom
which is good speaking to your mom know
that however phone comes first
okay no I you know that maybe there's
there's chance maybe your own in the
making for a cinema
worshiping more than everything but the
reality is that how many people left
never come back
how many people like even Canada
um
what do you think
I'm not gonna put pressure on you and I
don't want to keep you for love what
about you
do you take something oh yeah
all right
Cinema what you're going to watch review
who's that
I haven't been Cinema for years